les 5 millions d'internautes français
vont faire la fête durant tout le
week-end l'objectif de la fête de
l'internet est d'apprendre aux néophytes
à surfer sur le web le vocabulaire est
souvent austère et parmi les nouveaux
mots à la mode sur le net figure le
sigle mp3 à l'origine il s'agit d'un
procédé technologique pour compresser le
sont mais aujourd'hui mp3 est surtout
synonyme de sites qui proposent
gratuitement de la musique une musique
susceptibles d'être recopier c'est à
dire piraté un phénomène qui inquiète de
plus en plus l'industrie du disque et
notamment les chanteurs comme eddy
mitchell reportage dominique vadel et
jean christophe duclos
à les ordinateurs différents moteurs
et me suis dit les connaît bien les
voleurs et leur piratage étudier dans ce
laboratoire ici on simule tout ce qui se
fait sur internet où foisonnent décide
illégaux proposant parmi d'autres les
chansons d'eddy mitchell tous offrent de
la musique compressée au fameux format
mp3 et c'est un jeu d'enfant on se
connecte ont choisi les chansons un clic
et les titres se retrouvent ni vu ni
connu sur son disque dur d'ordinateur
sur le fond ce qu'on veut
pourrait jouer il suffit alors d'un
graveur et on a fabriqué son propre cd
quasi gratuitement un phénomène qui
explose depuis deux ans on estime que
dans les deux dernières années à peu
près 100 millions de cd vierges ont été
vendus pour à peu près 500 milles
graveur ce qui donne un ratio de 200 cd
vierges par graveur vendus on est en
droit de se demander ce que deviennent
effectivement ces deux sens et dégage
mieux même en france cette année il va
se vendre plus de cd vierges que deux
disques enregistrés et chez l'éditeur
d'eddy mitchell on rappelle qu'un disque
sur deux est piraté doit manque à gagner
d'un milliard de francs pour l'industrie
musicale française en 99 mp3 leur donne
de l'urticaire la solution c'est donc
une anti piratage en termes d'internet
c'est ce qu'on appelle alors messe des
amis qui va apparaître dans les mois qui
arrivent sur internet et qui est une
offre de musique sécurisé ça veut dire
que demain tout la musique légale aura
une norme qui ne pourra pas être
transmises ensuite en mp3 une mesure qui
ne semble pas impressionner les petits
génies d'internet il travaille déjà à la
contrecarrer notant que le marché des
ventes parallèles de céder dans les
lycées se porte toujours bien et là ils
coûtent jusqu'à dix fois moins chers que
dans le commerce